greetings to everyone my name is kashish
kundu and i am pursuing my master's
degree in bioinformatics at amity
university uttar pradesh india
this presentation is about my research
fellowship
at pine biotic on
in silico analysis of transcriptional
responses to uv and ir radiations in
skin cells
we all are aware about the harmful
effects of sun radiations on our skin
so to understand the
dna damage
caused by these radiations we use
microarrays
using microarrays transcriptional
reactions due to
various conditions are studied
in our case it's ir and uv radiation
these radiations affect our cell cycle
stress responses bodies cell repair
mechanism and many other functioning
in the dataset of our interest
microarray experiments were conducted on
10 000 genes from 15 healthy individuals
with no history of carcinoma
these cell lines were exposed to
radiations and data was recorded
this was a brief about the experiment
that was conducted
let's move to the pipeline we followed
for our analysis
this slide gives us a gist about the
followed workflow
upcoming slides we'll discuss briefly
about these steps and finally we will
move to the pictorial review of the
research
an appropriate data set was selected
which sufficed our interest
the data was downloaded and filtered
according to a requirement
and
unwanted information was removed
the data that is the expression table
was then
grouped
according to the test tested samples
into three major categories
namely
ir mock and uv
once the data was grouped various
statistical analysis were performed on
it particularly pca
which is principal component analysis
and manual calculation of
p adjusted
p value and forging calculation was
done forward to pathway analysis of the
genes
eilings and panther db were used
in bioinformatics
pathway studies play a huge role in
determining the key genes
or proteins that hold importance in the
trial or pathogenical conditions under
study
they also help in better understanding
of the mechanism of interest
ilynx is host to many
pathway analysis tools
which uh
sorry with many of their redirect
redirecting links attached with them
panther databases provide us with its
own
benefits of graphical representation of
functional pathways along with their
evolutionary analysis
now let's move to the pictorial
representation
this slide shows the series matrix data
that we downloaded
along with the group data
this is the group data after grouping
this is how it looked with
red representing ir green representing
mock data and
this blue color representing
uv data
this picture shows the david
david result
page of jail list which was obtained by
submitting the probe ids of the data set
using r the gene ids were merged with
the probe ids and
are presented in this picture
t bio platform is a
cloud-based uh package of big data
analysis big data analysis application
it offers numerous amount of numerous
pipelines to run our data and get the
analysis done
it also gives the user an option to go
through the demo pipelines
for for better understanding of the
functionality of platform
here pca results are shown before
grouping was done it was done to get an
idea about the distribution of the
samples
expression before grouping as well
after grouping three pc were run
they were mock versus
ir and uv
mark versus uv
and mock versus ir
both the pc's
in both the pcs nothing much of
significance was found
the samples were forming a scattered
carpet of plot
thus coming to a conclusion was
difficult
so we moved to the pathway analysis
this picture shows us the ilink's
homepage with various features
ready to be explored
this is the signature submission page
where we submit our signature and this
signature includes the gene ids the full
change value and p value as optional
category
after hitting submit
signature this output is recorded this
shows the signature analysis tools
which
we can perform
and get the information about pathways
networks or
general visualization of the genes
for this presentation i have included
the example of enricher
once the data is submitted on enricher
this is the page that opens up in front
of us with our gene results
here also we have different pi uh
pathways available for us to explore
i have opened king 2021 human
bar graph
this shows the expression level was a
high
cell cycle followed by other pathways
we can also use the cluster gram view to
view the
genes versus the pathway graph
it shows the genes here and the
expression level of various pathways
panther db
this is the uh
page where we submit the gene uh gene
list for gene list analysis these list
is submitted by a comma separated
file
and we select the require the
options from here like homo sapiens and
select the analysis
we want if you want a view if you want
to view the gene list this is the result
that is shown and for graph
we select the graph option to have a
graphical chart representation this is a
graphical chart representation of
panther db pathway
this is the pathway between ir and mock
and there are many peaks in it
which we'll discuss further
this is the uv versus mock
functional classification in barcha
and these are the color codings of
various pathways
results now in results uh we have many
top prop sets
uh
from out of those prop sets
the majorly that were explored were
stress response
cell cycle
proliferation cell structure signal
transduction apoptosis energy metabolism
and few other were there
the down regulated pathways showed more
expression in contrast to the
upregulated pathways
while going through the uv responsive
genes it was observed that around 59
percent of the genes were miscellaneous
as there was not much information that
was explored about their role
in
radiational effects on the skin
nonetheless
significant number of genes were
selected which has the relevance to the
query pathways
ir and uv genes showed similar
distribution
in functional pathway
from these results we interpreted that
if there is an uh
due to the exposure to the radiation to
the cell lines there will abrupt
activities
of cell line of sorry of cell cycle and
energy metabolism
that caused
skin lesions
and
which may further lead to carcinoma
development
above
tortic cycles showed an increased
expression
which may be inferred as
a way in which the cells
the components are
aiding in prevention of further
proliferation of the abnormal cells or
there is a breakdown of essential
cellular components
the outcome
proposed that protein translation is
additionally hindered by
halted transcription of trna synthetase
genes
these were the references
this was the paper from which the
datasets main analysis was done
and followed by some other
references
at last
but not the least i would like to thank
my mentors and pine biotech faculties
for helping me in my fellowship have a
great day ahead